[Music]
Rhianna shares royal wedding night
advice for Megan markle's I think you
have to go to the extreme ET spoke with
the 30 year old singer on Thursday in
NYC at the pop-up shop for her new
lingerie line savage venti with the
royal wedding coming up May 19th RiRi
shared this cheeky tip for Megan and her
soon-to-be hubby Prince Harry well the
easy I think you have to go to the
extreme when you're gifting for both a
man and a woman because both people
benefit from the gift we have a bridal
vibe going on you definitely do have a
little skirt and a top situation but I
mean really on your wedding night you
could do whatever you want it depends on
how savage you want to be because women
love to be sexy speaking of sexy Rihanna
also opened up about her incredible Pope
inspired Margiela Met Gala ensemble I
mean it took a lot of work it took a lot
of work and a lot of I mean hand beading
and you know I I appreciate the art so I
had another option that was a lot more
simple seem Marcella but I couldn't like
I felt like it was an insult to the
people who sat there and like can't beat
it that entire thing to just say no put
that in the archives right you know it
was it was so great I couldn't deny
it was heavy every step was a squat I
promise you it my my but gain for that
thing
[Music]
[Applause]